we're told a yoga mat is three-fifths of
a meter wide and has an area of one and
two twenty-fifths square meters what is
the length of the mat
well we know that length times width is
going to give you area
or another way of thinking about it if
the product of two numbers gives you a
third number if you take that third
number and divide it by one of these
you're going to get the other one so
another way of thinking about it is
length it would be the same thing as
area
divided by width
so we're trying to figure out the length
here we have the area we have the width
so our length is going to be one and two
twenty-fifths one and two twenty-fifths
divided by
three-fifths
now this is going to be the same thing
as let me write this as an improper
fraction it's going to be easier to do
some arithmetic with it so one is the
same thing as 25 twenty-fifths plus two
twenty-fifths this is twenty-seven
twenty-fifths
divided by
three-fifths
and we've already talked about how this
is saying how many three-fifths can fit
into twenty-seven twenty-fifths and
we've given the intuition why this is
the same thing as just multiplying 27
twenty-fifths times the reciprocal of
three-fifths
which is
five
thirds
and so this is going to be equal to and
actually i'm going to factor this out a
little bit to simplify things a bit
27 is 3 times 3 times 3 25 is 5 times 5.
so this is going to be equal to in our
numerator we're going to have 3 times 3
times 3 times 5 3 times 3 times 3 times
5
and then in our denominator we're going
to have 5 times 5 times 3
5 times 5
times 3 and then we can reduce this a
little bit we can divide both the
numerator and the denominator by five we
can divide both the numerator and the
denominator by three so in the numerator
we're gonna have three times three which
is nine
fifths so this is all going to be equal
to
nine-fifths so the yoga mat is
three-fifths of a meter wide and
nine-fifths of a meter long
now let's make sure that this makes
sense so i'm gonna make a grid so this
right over here
is one-fifth
of
a meter one-fifth of a meter in that
dimension and one-fifth
of a meter in that dimension
and then we can see well if it's this is
one-fifth of a meter then the width
right over here is three-fifths
of a meter and our length right over
here we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine fifths
it is nine fifths
now each of these units what is its area
well it is 1
25th
meter squared and how many of these do
we have well we can see we have
three rows of nine which is 27 of these
twenty-fifths so we're gonna have 27 25
square meters which is the same thing as
one and two-fifths square meters